in this current climate I am somewhat
ashamed to say that I used to watch
Destiny at certain points of his career
I have always been a fan of eccentric
nutcases yelling each other and Once
Upon a Time Destiny was a good source
for that content but unfortunately for
my viewing tastes this is all over he's
on his ADHD meds and the viance has
cured Destiny so now he no longer needs
to be in constant drama with other
communities and set women on each other
for his own pleasure but what takes its
place the endless research content
interspersed with self- glazing became
entirely unwatchable and I fully checked
out of keeping up with any of his
content but despite that I did try to
courau the dgg audience with some of my
old videos my Dan Clancy hitpiece got
shared on the subreddit and I somewhat
cynically saw this as an Avenue for
viewership and it took a while to dawn
on me that due to the Tendencies of the
people in this audience that it would be
an awful idea to CAU these people in
this way this realization came to me
when reading the comments on my Bad
Bunny video in this video I make a off
handed joke saying hanan's a Chad and
he's never done anything wrong and I
even added an Autism accessibility
feature in the next line saying can
actually hasn't done anything wrong but
as soon as certain people hear something
positive about Hanan no matter the
context their brains immediately short
circuit this isn't even a funny bit that
I'm proud of but it does go to show how
certain people cannot deal with anything
there isn't a Relentless affirmation of
their beliefs and let's be real for a
second at this point would you rather be
drinking champagne of the streamer
Awards with Ronaldo or getting plugged
up at a progressive Victory event with
Brianna woo and that brings us to the
allegations I don't wish to dwell on
this too much I'm expecting if you've
been brought to this video you're well
aware of everything going on right now
but after doing an interview with Nick
Mullen so depressing and bad it causes
him to retire many serious and in my
opinion irredeemable allegations came
out about Destiny causing him to take a
little break but don't worry it's not
over for the Omni liberal movement
Destiny's back with a face so smooth
it's quite uncanny and a cute little
chain this guy's got some full-on Mark
Zuckerberg swag now and his signature
abrasive tone is now replaced with a
super cool and laid-back style when I'm
when I'm speaking to my community or my
fan base there's like a lot of other
people that are out there and who are
not looking for anything good whatsoever
uh
don't don't mind yourself paying
attention to the haters that we're
always going to hate no matter what and
yeah he can't really address anything
now which does make sense because he's
in severe legal trouble and it's obvious
I didn't have high hopes for his
comeback dream to be some crazy drama
filed spectacle and all of his fans are
back it's business as usual they're
lapping it up and showering him with
praise and look he's going to tell us
all how to feel about Elon Musk people
try to post the videos comparing these
things but we are so back dgg we are
back who cares about the allegations
it's an election year oh wait it's not
that it's going it's not going to work
this time but Trump is in power and the
only thing that can stop him is an 8,000
viewer live stream with an audience of
shut and redditors the Goon day while
listening to some gnomes say Trump bad
and that's truly all it's going to be at
the minute I think the most
controversial it's going to get for now
is reacting to the OD asmin gold clip if
you don't like it I mean you need to
have people who represent you that are
making stuff that speaks more I guess to
The Souls of of the people that I guess
don't like [__] like that I don't know
but
do you think the Dems would have better
odds in future elections if the left
just stop this [__] entirely truly
enthralling stuff but Destiny I have a
burning question when are you going to
get some freaks back on to fight with um
I will say that over the past year like
2024 I've kind of like distanced myself
from like a lot of these communities and
now 2025 obviously we've had the the
master distancing for for a ton of
people so hopefully we continue to move
in that direction or not actually no we
don't move in that direction anymore
that's done um now we're like hardcore
[__] separated can you blacklist some
of these people yeah I'm probably
there's a lot of these people I'm
probably just never talking to ever
again we have now entered the dgg
Fortress Arc it is somewhat involuntary
but I will be interested to see due to
just how disgusting what is coming to
light about this guy is if he will be
able to roam free in the marketplace of
ideas once again cuz this guy does need
his debate look at these recent
highlights Tim pool react watching the
news o an h3h3 react boom here's a
totally new and novel idea for Destiny's
content talking at length about why
hanan's bad who cares who cares at this
point I do get it it's perfectly
rational to hate Hanan he's an
incredibly hatable person but how do
people not get that this criticism is
ineffective every time it happens he's
just going to brush it off and carry on
like normal I can give H3 a bit of the
pass because this is a newfound hatred
for him but for Destiny and these dggs
it's been long overdue them packing it
in I guess watching the news is actually
the best that Destiny's got at the
minute Anna casan versus Emma vigilin
beef I saw this Anna has gotten insanely
Petty that the clip that franchis is
using is misleading and totally out of
context but that's okay but I know that
no it's not okay stop if you say
something is out of context then explain
what the context is what is going on
with this Sizzle whel this is the best
you've got this is the hot moment from
this 30 minute segment when it's this
bad just don't have a Sizzle reel it's
almost warning the viewer that
absolutely nothing entertaining is going
to happen in this video If you say
something is out of context then explain
what the context is bit random but what
is going on here these cameras are far
too high fidelity for these two people's
faces sorry back to it look at these
thumbnails and I thought vos's guy was
phoning it in this is just a screenshot
from the news and he's put pain in
yellow text there I'm going to say it
again a little explosion in the
background can go go a long way people
that have seen my vosch content will
notice some similarities to this video
and they wouldn't be wrong because now
more than ever there are seemingly a lot
of similarities between Destiny and
vosch they're both political streamers
they're both most probably disgusting
sex freaks and they both make incredibly
boring content where they just sit there
and look at the news it seems mental to
me that Destiny and his audience would
rip into Vos so heavily for this style
of content but now destiny does it it's
all dgg have ever asked for they just
want a cool guy to tell them that
Trump's bad at this point Destiny could
sell dgg branded GRL made of soilent and
lumps of plastic and these followers he
has would be praising it as an
Innovative new culinary experience I
will be fair and say he does talk more
than vosch does but we are setting the
bar incredibly low here but can't these
viewers just try watching the news for
themselves call me crazy but I think
it'll be a far more fulfilling
experience to research things read
things and learn things yourself think
critically about the things that you've
learned and come to your own conclusions
rather than just have some guy tell you
what he thinks about it and I have
actually been researching another drama
of Destinies that has taken up way too
much of my spare time and I severely
regret it but it's unbelievable just how
a switch has flipped somewhere in my
head and it's made everything this guy
says sound so unhinged so this clip is
from the Bob s drama and it's kind of
shaky as to where the Bob s unconsented
and newed to somebody personally I think
big boss OS is pure evil and the fact
that Destiny had to edit audio to make
the allegation go down easier is telling
but this is Destiny's reasoning as to
why it's so obvious Bob would do such a
thing he screen shared those nudes with
Bose because he's trying to [__] Bose
because he wants to get on a good side
and one of the ways to do that is to
show nudes of other women 100% that's
what happened he is mental and he always
has been what I wish for is when all
this legal stuff passes over he just
Embraces the chaos just become the most
low brow Jerry bring a IBS style stream
because for me serious political
coverage is always going to be haunted
by the specters of his many victims but
his cult-like fan base don't care so I
guess that's just a pipe dream and we
are simply going to drown in the
mediocrity of Destiny becoming a clone
of vosch that was once a clone of
Destiny so yeah a quick update I've been
working like crazy on this Bob s video
and I don't even know if it's going to
come out it seems it seems a bit [__]
but I have got a bread tube video in the
works that I'm hoping is going to come
out quite good so please do stick around
for that thanks for watching